kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are married i'm just living life and
whatever happens happens
according to multiple reports the
lovebirds made things official during a
ceremony in las vegas just hours after
their pda filled night at the grammy
awards
gordon trav reportedly tied the knot at
the one love wedding chapel beautiful
amazing now to say the couple has had a
whirlwind romance is an understatement
courtney travis's love story began in
early 2021 with a source telling e.t at
the time they've had a platonic
relationship for years but recently
something sparked and it turned romantic
i love you
[Music]
in february the two made their
relationship ig official then continue
to show their love for one another all
across social media i love it and all
that love and affection turned into an
engagement travis popped the question in
october proposing to court on the beach
in front of a lavish floral display and
on the family's new hulu reality series
the kardashians fans will see how it all
went down one of the biggest things in
her life is about to happen and courtney
has no idea
do you know what they say first comes
love then comes marriage then travis and
i want to have a baby
yep travis and courtney have plans to
expand their blended family put the
sample in this cup
we'll take our mics off you know get the
audio a source tells e.t that the idea
of adding to their bunch is very
important and exciting to them of course
court already has three kids of her own
with ex scott disick 12 year old mason
nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign
and travis he shares two kids with
ex-wife shana moekler 18 year old landon
and 16 year old alabama you know my main
concern is always you know my my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
travis and i you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness as for court and travis
nuptials it's unclear if the stars are
illegally wed as of tuesday there's no
record of a marriage license for them in
clark county nevada but there's a chance
the celebrations are just getting
started back in january source told e.t
the couple is planning an intimate and
special wedding
both courtney and travis are so looking
forward to spending the rest of their
lives together as soul mates
[Music]
you